[Music]
in literal mom porn news oh hell yeah I
see that every night oh that's sweet
okay submitted by see bondage what where
are we going with this one okay a group
of moms decided to make their own porn
that they would gladly show their kids
what does about to be like sexy [__]
boy did you have another dream boy they
do I get flabbergasted like wait they
[__] their husbands or their boyfriend
and record it and then they want to
share that with their kids no okay cuz
that's what bones just said that's
that's what Tiffany made me say the
article made Tiffany right that's what
TIFF
that's what the article make Tiffany
right to make both saying I don't want
to watch my mom [__] even if she was
young
okay this is a group of five mothers
that are part of a new show on channel 4
those takes place in the UK called mums
make porn and so part of this show is
that they had to do their research and
they found that they were very disgusted
with the type of porn that is found
online today yeah they pretty much
directed this their own porn that they
would gladly show their children because
they're saying that they're so porn as
of today we're natural it doesn't show
like a realistic woman or like how sex
really is why it's porn yes you could
get away from it it's fantasy we get the
regular [__] that's why we want the
weird [__] yeah oh she's talking about
how kids these days are exposed to porn
they think that's the real [__] no we
want the weird [__] but they end up
thinking that that's what they're gonna
get once they start having sex I have a
four and a half inch penis man having
sex with them oh god that's so boring I
would never want who doesn't really want
him and has to warm her up to 30 minutes
this bread kids think it like this is
porn that these moms would be
comfortable as their children were how
do they know that their kids aren't
watching webcam horn between husband and
wife yeah cuz that
also you you know that's a gateway drug
because like when I see that point I'd
be like he's they've been porn and I'm
gonna start looking for like you know
I'm gonna start looking for like they
were saying that let's get weird you're
saying that they so what mother was
reduced to tears because she was she had
to look at violent rape based porn a lot
of people do you want you I've seen it
but I don't I don't like it we've seen
it but it's it's it's just a little bit
harder than like bondage I mean there's
some that's cool but you're talking
about like this want this mom she ended
up throwing up okay like crying yeah it
was pretty like and some of it is vile
dude well I mean how do they know what
their kids sexual taste will be because
not all of them will click that [__] it
is not your turn more but I don't like
that kind of war it's not determined by
the porn like the porn does not shape
your sexual interest because like you
know y'all know when you're scrolling
through and you're like you click on
this and then it just starts getting
weirder and weirder you know what I mean
like you sell filter you go I don't know
about this one man their gang raping
this this little person you guys are
adults already so I guess you've already
understand no because my porn career
started very early in life and I've
built that this this accessible like
kids no mine started very late mine
started very late so like I started like
going through stuff and I was like oh I
like that and I already like that it has
to do with your life experience there's
not really the porn you want let me tell
you this you I I was it might taste
changed I used to love come faces now
why would you do that to her
yeah in junior high I was like I love
anal ain't no so cool and you're
watching porn you're like anal looks
good you [__] that booty and there's
Dookie on your dick you no longer want
to do ain't no ever in life mmm emotion
Joe you're weird you know what what if
like okay a plot twist because they
never really said anything about the
fetishes they said something about
realistic and like realistic bodies what
if these are moms that weren't
necessarily happy with their bodies and
so they were like well we need to show
sons like what a real woman's body
looked like and it's more about their
ego rather than their cuz what is the
moms fattest [__] and they're like
that's not a real woman's body well just
gonna shut you up so these are hating in
this TV show it will be like some
[__] liberal as LBGT looking mom they
came together they look like they were
casted by a television network they have
the perfect balance if like we need a
black one let's get the ones who want to
do it go back to the other I mean this
one looks more normal you know what in
the UK there's a lot more diversity bro
like I do seen the shows yeah like I see
Indian people Asian people and I'm like
this is so dope why can't we do this
year yeah I'm edition looks like they're
about to go protest be friends they're
about to go protest being a [__]
dildo they're about to go protests on
some abortion rights kind of [__] I
think it's the face she makes for split
up your butt so I can see what they're
no they're actually some hot moms
thought I could see where they're coming
from because so this in disdain like
back in our era it was the chicks like
the chicks in school they felt pressure
from like the magazine covers right like
oh this is so unrealistic there's an
unrealistic portrayal of women or
whatever and then they already have that
pressure in this day and age like a
little 12 13 year old girl they feel
because of all the people are barred up
with way more unrealistic pressures so
now you have 12 13 year olds that want
plastic surgery like they want to change
their face or their haven't even fully
developed yet they want to do all this
crazy [__] so I can only imagine I can
only imagine in the porn realm if
they're that influenceable now I'm in
the porn wrong if they immediately if
they don't have their taste yet like
both and they go influenceable
what's the word personable in
professional first of all they're not
impressed not yeah but like both was
lucky to know what her tastes are and
this
you can go search porn and enough that's
her fantasy room but if you don't have
your roots set yet and you think fantasy
is real life and you are influenceable I
can see how I can [__] [__] because if I
was a 12 year old girl not saw porn and
I'd be like man guys like their dick
written that hard I better learn how to
[__] him how this [__] on that scream
every time now like that's how you show
that it's good screaming but it's like
no I'm imagining you bleeding at 17 like
ble et what is that like a goat no but I
like what they're doing like I think
it's cool and I think they're also
making it for kids that don't have
parents that talk to them about sex you
know what I mean the kids that need that
guidance but then they're exposed to so
much [__] so quickly yeah then they're
saying that like the porn industry it's
mainly ran by men so then they're it's
always like through the guys fantasy
lens so I love the female directors I'm
a big Dana Jamison was a good director
for a minute oh you know actually on
board with this because like I'm just
now getting to the age where like the
body is not what it once was when I was
like 19 I had the little Abercrombie
shirts and like the halter tops now you
know I had like a butt and I was like
yeah this is good now I'm not kind of
getting like stretch marks I feel like
my skin's not as tight as it was you
know things are not like the factory is
like losing employees you know the
factory boys are retiring losing their
eyes like holding things up and like a
few people started leaving like dudes
like [__] Jeff left last week and I'm
like Jesus Christ you know like hey you
don't look like Detroit yet so don't
don't - yeah I feel like an old car
factory like that's your atha Oh check
this out though I feel like Warren is
much more body-positive than everything
else like more than high-fashion more
than any of that more than swim
especially parties yeah
because so like what girls watch in porn
is different from what guys watch right
like guys will develop like attraction
to something that's not stereotypically
attractive like girls that a little bit
more chunkier or maybe girls that are
like not know what porn you know you
start to find hot
and things that you start to acquire
your own taste like you're like oh [__]
I never really realized I loved poof
poofy areolas that's something that's
not stereotypically beautiful right but
you're like what the poofier it's like a
bigger areola oh that's yeah squid eye
yeah and then like it in like so like in
and there's there's like so many a
variety of women it looks like you're
about to go into a musical right now
dude there's so much variety
[__] [__] areola they're short girls
there's petite girls there's tall girls
are old ladies there's young ladies
there's like you look like you're
opening a sub porn circus with the hat
on tall short Oh [__] factory do girls
for girls one go by guys in one go what
all these eight-year-olds now are like
[__] this sounds exciting let's go to
porn
no but yet known is it all of it in it I
think they're talking about one type of
porn and it's the most boring basic type
of well I think they're also talking
about just how to [__] do it
right cuz the point is the sting should
over and over again the girl sucks his
dick she's like Toki she's got like over
and then like you guys just [__]
pounding away dicks like this big if
she's gonna [__] yeah I'm doing one
of these things like she's trying yeah I
think they're probably touching on that
as well where it's like you don't have
to it's not a race like go slow you know
so haven't you guys like I feel like
once you get a little older you decide
like oh I'll try amateur porn you know
I'm like I'll watch like a call that's
my [__] but you don't get to that that's
like it it's like when you get older
you're like yeah I need that passion I
need to like watch that cuz it's like I
like to watch boyfriends and girlfriends
[__] cuz you could see that [__] and I
feel like that
that's the more normal one so I feel
like they're about to put like every
unflattering angle like it's gonna be
over in four minutes like it's gonna be
like too real you know I used to like
watching that I I would specifically
type guy comes too fast cuz I'll watch
it on my like cuz she's so good he could
handle it hi yeah did you feel connected
today no no I was just funny to me
watch that do you guys never see those
who haven't really enjoyed porn then
there's some funny [__] to watching a
lot of porn dude you make it something
exciting
it is like it's been a minute man it's
too crazy for me dude this is way too
wild your eyes alright
especially because there's like one spot
like there's like this more it's like
music right you have your pop music
there's a pop music oh my god that's
what this that's what they're talking
about
it's like this is what the most basic
people like they get aroused by this
it's the same like what you said same
structure oh [__]
you will learn piano suck my dick and
then it's like bang Oh missionary doggy
stop missionary doggy style an
occasional upside down and in this and
down and it's you know it always has to
go a you know at the end and then now
it's anal and then [__] come to the
face I want to be like it's the same
structure more realistic like midway
through you're about to change positions
and his phone rings you say who is that
you have to come out you know that's why
I like I like the company I like that I
like to come too fast because it catches
you off-guard
cuz it's like oh he's POW DS is too good
and he busts inside her he's like oh I'm
sorry I came too fast and I'm like
that's real sex right there
how long are those video clips return
self ass like did you see the [__]
beginning role and the milk is fast you
do
done
[Music]